he's more classical he likes to occupy
the center with pawns slowly maneuver
bring his pieces out
and uh
yeah this one
yeah it's definitely going to heat up
later but i'll tell you if i'm getting
worried already we talked about the
clock situation and yeah he's still got
12 and a bit minutes left but yeah
things are going to heat up he needs
that time for later exactly and uh
he's taking the time to consider what
type of
position he should be going for so now
he castles the king it's a very natural
move and after knight takes pawn it's
here where he has to make that decision
and he's done it he's actually pushed
his pawn forward see pawn two squares
that's actually not the main line the
main line was actually developing the
knight
on the left side
yeah so uh will this move cause magnus
to think he's just still tucking away
into his noodles um yeah ivanka you're
right this one for me is a bit odd as
well
black trying to get some influence over
the center so it looks logical this